[Music]
casey's with us in milwaukee wisconsin
hi casey welcome to the ramsay show
hello um
thanks for answering um i just had a
question so i have a job interview today
and probably like 20 minutes or so oh
and i was just wondering um
when do i ask about like the salary in
the interview process so
i
know the super one of the supervisors
that's interviewing me and he told me
what the pay should be for the position
but when i looked online it said a
different pay than what he had told me
so i just wanted to figure out how to
navigate that yeah is this your first
interview
yes yeah do not ask about it in the
first interview
if it's something appropriate that
they're going to bring up in the first
interview then you can ask questions
when you get to that stage and in any
kind of normal healthy interview process
there'll come a time where they make you
an offer at which point you can ask any
questions around the offer but uh if you
know him well that would be the one
asterisk dave i it feels like because he
knows him and he and because he's
already mentioned it to you
you could say maybe when the interview's
done go hey uh you mentioned this in our
in our last conversation and i was just
doing some research on the company
online i saw it was a different thing is
there is it what's the difference in
that and just kind of maybe because you
know him and if you feel the interview
went well uh i would think that's a
that's an asterisk for me on that one is
that what do you think about that what
was the pay you were told and what was
the pay online
um the pay he told me so it's it's
salary position so it'd be about 900 a
week and i think online it said like 750
800 i think it said 800 on mine
it was about 100 difference a week
okay
all right it's five thousand dollars
difference a year it's worth knowing of
the difference on it um yeah but um but
is that is that a deal breaker either
way
um
i'm so i'm going to this job from a job
that pays more but this will give me a
lot more work-life balance so
i'd rather not take that much of a
decrease
okay so it is a deal breaker
yeah and so um yeah i think you bring it
up towards the end of the interview if
the interview is going well and you feel
like it's heading on you know
um yeah but if it's not going well that
just the fact that you're preoccupied
with the income might be enough to throw
you out
okay yeah if the first thing out of
somebody's mouth in an interview with me
is how much do you pay and what are the
benefits i figure they're coming here
for what they can get rather than what
they can give yeah
and i want people that add value that
are not takers and so if the first thing
the first three minutes of the interview
all you want to talk about is how much
you're going to get paid
um that's a sign you're coming to
collect money not coming to add to value
and um and that'll end the interview
process if it's with me i'll be kind
about it but i'm done
that's it so you do have a button that
you push and they don't know where the
chair drops to it's eject yeah it just
disappears